welcome everyone those here at yale
participating in person and the many
more that are participating
participating via zoom my name is
claudia valencia i am a professor of
anthropology here at yale and the chair
of the council on latin american and
liberian studies and
it is a great pleasure to
introducing you to our guest today so i
am delighted to welcome you to and our
distinguished guest to the first event
of the latin american policy leader
leader series
the series and this is a mouthful the
series is generously supported by the
george herbert walker junior lecture
fund in international studies at the
macmillan center for international area
studies
[Music]
first
a brief thanks
should be longer but it proves thanks to
the many people involved in organizing
today's event
our team team at class particularly
agustina anesha and josh
for
being wonderful a wonderful thing
supporting
this
this event
then the fox international fellowship
program the program on peace and
development at the yale macmillan center
and the office of international affairs
thank you all
before i introduce our speaking speaker
and moderator today i want to share a
few words about our latin american
policy leaders series
latin america is the home to some of the
world's largest democracies
and the region has made enormous strides
in consolidating democratic norms and
human rights since the end of the cold
war
the latin american policy leader series
seeks to create dialogue about the
future of democratization human rights
and development with policy leaders from
across the region
our hope is to engage these leaders in
vigorous and respectful discussion about
pressing issues
as part of the series we are pleased to
be to welcoming the former environmental
ministry of ecuador and president of the
world wildlife fund international
yolanda kakawaze on may on march 11th so
mark your calendars
on april 19th we will host a discussion
with the president of the inter-american
court of human rights rigardo perez
manrique
and on may 20th we will wrap up the
series with mariano el baeza
regional director of latin american and
the caribbean for the un women
now regarding today's event and our
speaker speaker i am delighted to
introduce the secretary general of the
organization of american states dr luis
almagro who is originally from uruguay
and is a lawyer by professor
he is currently serving his second term
as secretary general of the organization
of american states
the secretary general was your wise
foreign minister
between 2010 and 2015
during his tenure uruguay welcomed
former prisoner from guantanamo
granted asylum to dozens of syrian
families who were victims of civil war
and secured endorsement of the group of
latin american caribbean countries
grulac for its election to a seat on the
united nations security council in
january 2016.
he was also ambassador to china for
three years
after occupying senior diplomatic posts
in his country's foreign ministry
and its embassies in germany and iran
in addition he was elected as a senator
in year one's national elections in
october
october 2014.
luis almagro was first elected as
secretary general of the
oas in march 18 2015 with a support of
33 of the 34 member states and one
abstention
he was reelected for a second term on
may 20 2012.
after the secretary's general remarks
our clients faculty member professor
anna delau will sit up in our living
room here
for a discussion before opening up for
questions and answer sessions with those
in this room and also attendees that are
joining us virtually
ana delawa is a professor in the
department of political science here at
yale and is also the director of
undergraduate studies
for latin american studies which is our
signature major and those
of you who are considering majors as
students please
contact anna or
the kleis for more information
she's also affiliated with the institute
of social and policy studies and the
jackson school of global affairs
her research relates to the political
economy of poverty alleviation
clientelism and the provisions of public
goods professor de la is the author of
numerous articles in journals such as
the american journal of political
science and the journal of politics as
well as the book crafting policies to
end poverty in latin america in
maastricht
she teaches courses on the political
economy of poverty alleviation paradigms
of political economy the politics of
redistribution and quantitative research
methods
thank you so much anna for lending your
expertise and moderating our
conversation today
i understand the secretary general will
uh make some brief remarks so please
listen in and be ready with any
questions uh for the q a
session
and i want to add a personal anecdote
here
i am here
presiding this event
in part thanks to the oas
i came to the united states to do my phd
with funding from the oas a loan
that we religiously paid
on monthly installments
that allowed us to uh pursue our our
degree without
having to work outside so thank you to
the away
so without further ado plea do please
join me in welcoming secretary general
of oys luis almagro
[Applause]
thank you very much
and to all of you
it's a great pleasure to be here
especially in democracy in latin america
and the caribbean progress and peace
development
if we see
the hemisphere of course
we may see some serious challenges
related to
the state of democracy
in some countries
the conditions for progress and
development
always uncertain
and the conditions of
peace are related to security matters
and of course the challenges that we
have in the hemisphere
so all this means that
we have a
i i will have to unleash some failures
related to all this
as you may imagine
democracy is not always so healthy
security is not always available for all
latino americans caribbean people
development development is always
uncertain in the hemisphere we always we
all
we need to do something else in order to
jump out of the trap of underdevelopment
that we always are
of course
for me there is an obvious conclusion
looking at the hemisphere the better the
democracy
the better the conditions for
development the better are the
conditions for security
better conditions for access to rights
and
equity democracy
it means
best possible citizens
best possible institutions as strong as
possible
efficient institutions that can deliver
to the people that can provide to the
people that can find solutions for for
the structural problems of the people
of course we have
some structural problems some of them
they have been with us
for the 200 years of independent life
i think
of course we have also
new wounds
old grievances new grievances
all goons new ones
we have a structural problem the past
200 years we are the most unequal
region in the world
and this is not just means
inequality in the context of
wealth distribution but also access to
rights we already unequal how people
access to write in our hemisphere
we still discriminate a lot we still
have a lot of serious challenges in
order to resolve
the conditions for everybody to have a
fair life and opportunities
in in the hemisphere we are facing
serious problems
uh related to this
inequality
it affects our democracies but
it affects also our levels of
development
with
a better democracy and of course we need
to have better conditions of equality in
the hemisphere better access to rights
for people and to be able
uh from there to have better conditions
for development
if we think that inequality is just a
political issue we are wrong
inequalities and issues cross-cutting
issues that affect practically every
level of life
of the life that we live in the
hemisphere
we have
of course a lot of challenges ahead
we have
to fix this
we have not worked hard in the past 200
years we have
a big problem about about that
i always mentioned the case of
the rules for the land reform of
artilles 1815
that refers that
in felicia
those more
those are unhappy those
most vulnerable to be the most
privileged in the context of politics
and he identified
the
the main vulnerable vulnerable groups in
the in in what it was about oriental
then
and they were
with the way with the wealth with
children
they were
after descending population they were
indigenous people
200 years later we have the same pattern
of
of poverty in the country we have single
mothers count
for a lot of the poverty of the region
of the of the country
um
after descendant people they account for
eight percent of the population and for
40 percent of the poverty
and indigenous people they were
exterminated after
the
independently after the independence so
they don't count anymore
that means we really
have some serious structural problems
because that that is considered the most
equal country in the
among latin americans
is still
the one that
still has the same very same structural
problems that he it has had for quite a
while
we are
um
we are supposed to come from very
liberal ideas or in the our independence
our constitutions they were like they
have a democratic vocation
most of them they
took the
thomas paine and they took the
principles of the american revolution of
the french revolution
but
when we scratch it a little bit
just a little bit
we know that we are highly paternalistic
we are an equal we have patterns of
races practically everywhere
we have
this poverty
structural poverty in the hemisphere so
we still have a lot to do to put this
liberal mind these liberal ideas these
advanced constitutional legislation into
practice to bring solutions for the real
people that it depends where they were
born
and the class the neighborhood
the region in the country
and of course race and gender and
other levels of inequality and
discrimination that exist in the
religion
and of course this all brings uh
patterns of exclusion and polarization
and i am
resuming the problems in order that we
those are the things that we need to
address we need to address this in order
to have better democracies we need to
address this in order to have
a better possibility for development
exclusion and polarization it comes with
uh
with this with what i have just said of
the levels of inequality
of this cross-cutting inequality in our
in our countries
we have
in the past in the past years we
even moved to further
uh polarization in in our countries
sometimes uh we have seen
in the region
[Music]
projects impossible to reconciliate
between each other
passing to the second round of elections
and
maybe sometimes
because citizens they look for radical
approach to for solutions sometimes on
one side or the other side sometimes
because
we are uh
we are
just losing the common ground sometimes
because we are not able to handle
properly the political discussion the
political participation that come with
social media we have all these
challenges ahead we have been it has
been very hard for us to develop a
substantial
and constructive and positive agenda
based on our political discussions and
we have been falling apart on in these
discussions becoming more and more
polarized polarized and
and not only polarizations and it goes
some sometimes to the enemization of the
political adversary what is even more
irrational
and it's not
and that brings another problem that is
you remain in power no matter what
and that remaining in power is always uh
the base for
some people of course to get some
immunity impunity or amnesty and it has
been proved in this hemisphere that
noditator is safe from the long memory
of human rights justice or the long arm
of human rights justice so that the only
way dictators remain impune is because
they remain in power that is the only
way for amnesty that is the only way for
immunity for impunity
the impunity that comes from remaining
in power whatever the cost
may be and we have seen in that sense
that we passed from one dictatorship in
the hemisphere to three dictatorships in
uh in some for five years six seven
years
maybe some processes were more
accelerated some processes were more
gradual but it went that that way
looking for these conditions of impunity
of immunity
and that
of course are the
the challenges of dealing also with a
zero-sum mentality that is uh
is um is taking a lot from us uh
it's like we are not able to find
the way that
we can work together but how we can
defeat the other and how we can take
advantage of that of that victory
we
we have to
we are looking for relevance in the in
the wrong way
we we need to look for relevance based
on the solutions that we find for our
people how we eliminate discrimination
how we eliminate poverty how we
eliminate inequality how we create
better conditions for the people to
integrate and to consolidate and common
ground that may allow institutions to
work in the long term to execute plans
in the long term to design plans in the
long term
all these it means sometimes going back
to square one institutions going back to
square one political system going back
to square one or just holding to power
in no matter no matter what no matter
how bad is your humanitarian crisis no
matter how bad this immigration crisis
matter how bad is your corruption no
matter how bad are your human rights
violations
just remain in power and that
that school of thought regrettably is
something that we also have in these
hemispheres also have we among latino
americans
[Music]
what we do
we deal with political systems is
we try to bring stability and we try to
strengthen democratic institutions we
try to create
conditions for transparent government
we try to create the conditions for the
better projects that can bring and
develop according to the pillars of the
organization democracy access to right
security
the thing is that
this is a a serious challenge and where
you you expect an organization
with um
not enough financial resources not
enough human resources to fix these four
pillars
in a
practically 100
efficient way
and
in a context of course that we have
today of
conflict
of social and political conflict
escalation
but the the solution is this
the oh yes it means multilateralism and
that it means
means stability that is what how we work
how we create conditions that can bring
better democratic governance and that is
how we push
more or less most of the time we
and be in a moral force and that is the
the thing of the organization i mean
our projects cannot have the scale of
financial institutions but we are we are
a strong moral force in creating
conditions that can help some
governments and governments democratic
governments and democratic institutions
to stabilize and to face
the threats that they have the threats
that they have that are related to
the existential threats that we have in
the in the hemisphere and i go
to caribbean and central american
countries for example
first of all
the one that is
challenging their own existence is
climate change i mean we have a group of
small islands that year by year are
devastated by hurricanes
two three countries
in like caribbean caribbean countries
central american countries they deeply
affected but what is going on in climate
change in the world and for us climate
change is not a rhetoric it's not a
speech it's not a it is something that
it brings a serious impact to millions
of people
thousands of people every every year we
are the first frontier of climate change
practically no other region has in the
world has this impact
serious impact every year that we are
facing
the other
existential threat is
is security we are
we have a serious challenge there and
something that we definitely need to to
address
we are eight percent of the world
population we count for 38 percent of
violent death
violent death uh
and we have 15 of the 20 most violent
cities in the world
we are definitely
far
to deliver solutions from
the
crisis and the terror that organized
crime and drug trafficking
is bringing to our countries in the
hemisphere
we have uh uh
we we have not been able to reverse that
i think we need a stronger and more
efficient institutions that definitely
each country can hardly
have in
if you look at the budget of a
drug trafficking organization compared
to what may have
you know police station somewhere in the
in in our in our countries definitely
they are far behind and they are
they have far uh
uh
stronger harder challenges than than
anybody
we need
we need international cooperation for
that we need the internal we need a
permanent engagement of developed
countries bringing better conditions of
security to our countries and of course
a better regional cooperation related to
this matter
and
and that at a certain moment that we can
depend ourselves because
our police is
much more professional because our
judges are
far more efficient and because our
prosecutors are better when they they
investigate we have all these challenges
in order to create
a security matrix uh for for for the
for the the continent
the and the other existential threat is
corruption
and
the conditions of lack of transparency
um definitely uh japanese are always
there we have not uh
we have not been able to overcome
maybe we are doing better than than in
previous in previous years but
more of the political system is
scrutinized more of the political system
is
is investigated and there are more
prosecutions related to corruption in
public affairs nevertheless we are far
from what it should be and
the fight of corruption starts to
avoiding that every government in action
is affected by that
it doesn't mean to
endorse the previous corruption but it
doesn't mean to persecute the previous
administration that it cannot it can
never work as a way of fighting
corruption
fighting corruption should be a general
thing starting by yourself by what you
do and
and the challenges that you have about
your own moral and
your republican property that you can
deliver
and therefore challenges of course the
fourth residential threat are
dictatorships and we are having more
dictatorships as i said and and they
really affect because they bring
all the bad practices uh to the to the
hemisphere and to the political systems
of the hemisphere it's uh
bad practices uh are very contagious uh
are very difficult to control even
to
to bring good practices uh from one
country to other you need a project you
need financing you need
experts you need a lot of work and
chronogram to execute that project
but practices they just spread without
nobody saying anything you're
suddenly you will see this and this and
this copying that and starting this
this
this way of doing things and that is why
to have dictatorships in the hemisphere
it's it's bringing a lot of
bacterial infections to to our our
democracies and i wish that one day we
can have an atmosphere
free of
free of a
human rights
violation free of crimes against
humanity
and that it will mean a step forward in
our development
mainly because these dictatorships you
see them they are mainly failed systems
they have failed completely in social
and production
terms and they are not they have not
been able and even one of them is
uh is one of the richest countries that
exists in the world with a lot of oil a
lot of mineral resources a lot of energy
a lot of whatever you want in this world
and not and now it's a broken country
how will you create that because of
applying
a formula that never worked uh it is a
formula of the the ideology of
dictatorship and this is not from for
the right or from the left it is the
formula of a dictatorship and that's why
i started saying in this semester what
we see is that better democracies better
development conditions better
security conditions better access to to
to right
we have
a lot
a lot ahead and
and definitely
we need to to address some of these
issues because they are like
running out of uh
of of control
human rights violations co
executives co-opting the judiciary
uh uh weak parliaments and all these it
needs to be built if we want to be
developed countries at a certain moment
if we have to have if we want to have
better conditions for the living of of
everybody in our in our societies
so um
is um
sometimes
people think this is a
gloomy
approach and i think i say i will never
be able to
resolve my problems if i don't face them
if i don't identify them i don't know
which are these problems that's why we
have to start from here if we want to
have
what the title
says
strengthening democracy for progress and
peace
that's it
[Applause]
hi everyone
claudia mentioned i'm anna delao and
thank you so much
so thank you so much to clies
wow i don't even feel it anymore
[Laughter]
thank you so much to clive for the
invitation to
moderate um
this panel and of course it's an honor
for me to be here
secretary general thank you so much
for those very thought-provoking remarks
and you have already touched on
a few of the things that i was
planning
to ask you about but i do want to start
with the point about strengthening
uh democracy as both claudia and you
secretary general mentioned the region
has made great strides at consolidating
a representative democracy
but there are signs of democratic
backsliding in some countries of course
and the democratic breakdown
in in some cases and also according to
the last latin american public opinion
project only 60 percent of latin
americans would say that they prefer
democracy to any other
system of government which is
quite alarming
and so i i wonder secretary general
whether we should we have been focusing
too much on
the role of elections and free and fair
elections in the region and whether you
think that there is now room
to think about more direct forms of
democratic participation
and also your remarks made me think when
you talked about polarization
inequality security problems whether you
think the region
should be going in that direction or not
to more direct forms of participation
the first thing democracy is uh
is a work for everybody i mean
we start from the
we have to start from the very beginning
we have to be
better citizens
more tolerant citizens and more flexible
and
more looking at the perspective of what
solutions we can achieve and how we can
build
better things for our society
so i
i always hope that uh
we we we can engage in better informing
people
and and being closer to the people
in order to bring
solutions and that
that
may help everybody to to to be a better
citizen
of course this is not uh
not the only thing i mean we need to
have a stronger institution so you were
referring to
to some uh
surveys and polls that
of course
there is not so
much of trust in democracy these these
days
and
[Music]
but
this is this makes me remember
a phrase
that my mother used to say that
and
you never know that you're fine until
you are not fine anymore and
and we have seen that
because
those that they miss democracy
in cuba venezuela those are in nicaragua
they really want
they want democracy back in their
countries
so
those that they are
not so happy with democracy these days
is because of course
they are maybe more unhappy
and happy about
lack of efficiency of their governments
or
maybe
not so good democratic governance itself
so that is the biggest the biggest issue
but
we can build better democracies also
building better institutions we need
better institutions these days we need
institutions that can
help us with solutions and can help us
in real time
if you don't have institutions you stop
helping people if
some countries they have structural
problems and the institutions are have
been very weak for decades or maybe more
and you have some countries where the
deterioration of institutions have been
more of a gradual thing until they they
are completely useless and uh
i don't like to mention country but the
case of venezuela is is an example of
that suddenly the the minister of health
cannot deliver solutions in the health
system
the minister of food but cannot
feed all the people of the country
the security
[Music]
the ministry of interior cannot help
people related to security matters
and not they cannot even protect the
territory i mean they
the armed forces of venezuela went to
fight the dissident of dissident of farc
in apuria and they and they took a as
his
heart
punishment beaten so it's not even they
can control the territory properly so
that is when you deteriorate
institutions to a level that you cannot
help anybody
and you cannot deliver solutions for
anybody
so you need institutions that can be
efficient
uh
the messianic approach is of course a
different a different way i mean you
the the the messiahs they don't need uh
they don't need the strong institutions
they come by themselves and they and
they and they
resolve everything but that at the end
you see that that doesn't happen and and
in the process
the deterioration of institutions can
bring the country to a new level of of
problems
if we are ready to
more direct forms of democracy
we are already doing more direct forms
of democracy we are participating
uh every day in politics wherever we are
and uh
you're based on whatever is your country
you are able to participate in the
political life there because
you have a twitter a facebook account
and then you can
really
create conditions for public opinion and
you can
bring new issues to the political system
and it's a it's a new way of
participating is a much more direct one
and i
and i i agree with that with that
but
that doesn't resolve everything that
democracy needs i mean
as i said we need to face the problem of
inequality we need to fail to resolve
the problems of security so
we need to create conditions to better
produce in the country and and that it
cannot be done only chatting in a in
twitter or
or in a in a social media there you have
to really work and sometimes the people
forget that politics is working in
service i mean you serve people and
you serve people with uh with the
purpose of making your society better
but you have to do things and you have
to be a doer you have to do if you if
you only want to talk about politics
yeah maybe the social media will end
only replacing
our
very very serious conversations that we
had in our bars and cafes in latin
america but will not hardly be enough to
solve our problems
yeah
and
so since you were now talking about
inequality so that seems to be a very
big structural ancient problem in latin
america there was a point in time in the
2010s
more or less where it seems that some
countries had experienced a small
decrease in inequality and people
started getting very excited about
seeing a change in the trend in
inequality but of course even before the
pandemic
that a
reason for hope was already
um
we didn't have enough reason to hope
that the trend was going to continue in
that direction so i'm just wondering
you mentioned corruption you mentioned
inequality you mentioned discrimination
it all points to
to to perhaps a broken social contract
in many of these countries that it's a
very complicated problem because
um if governments don't have
access to resources so it's tax revenues
are low people don't want to pay taxes
people don't trust that other people are
going to want to pay taxes
and
it sort of traps countries in a negative
equilibrium in a way in a very
a
negative cycle i'm just wondering
how to get out of it and i wonder
whether organizations like the oas has
sort of a vision of how to promote
maybe
tax agreements i don't know exactly what
would be the way forward
and is there room for international
cooperation to get the country moving in
the right direction
international cooperation is always
necessary and
[Music]
and you always have to
to refer to some
some country some states and nations
that can be doing the things in the in
the in the right way
so international cooperation and and you
may need
the assistance and the cooperation of
these countries in order to
better do a couple of things that you
want to do in your your country my
country
um
yeah
i was part of a government that
reduced inequality as much as we could
and we reduced poverty to one visit
in
uruguay
for
and and that is uh
uh
it can be done it can be done and
sometimes people refer to muhitam they
prefer
a lot more his philosophical part
i
highly appreciate more his
professionalism he was a professional
doing his job
he worked
from
very early in the morning
i was sure that if i would i was having
a call half past six in the morning it
would come from him
and i was sure that
if i was getting a cold at 11 in the
evening it would be from him and that he
would have
20 meetings in a day and that he would
be on
trying to deal with practically every
single matter that exists in the country
otherwise we have very few so you can do
a lot of micromanagement when
even you are
at the same time you can be doing high
politics and uh it can be done it can be
done and you have to have the purpose of
that of course
you have to
have the purpose of bringing
more equal conditions to your people if
you don't have that purpose you won't do
it but uh even if you work a lot but
that
is a is a thing you have to
uh to bring these these solutions and
it's and it's possible to it's possible
to achieve and um
and i and it can be done
and of course
and that is what i mean when
uh but you have to work the things in
the long term
it is not enough
to work for a couple of years or to work
for 10 years to work for 20 years i mean
we are in a
station that we need to to work very
hard for for for longer than
than that
if our social contract is broken now our
i think our our social the social
contract that we have and that's why i
mentioned inequality discriminations
paternalistic et cetera et cetera et
cetera
it was a failed
social contract maybe it's not broken
and that is the problem maybe they are
trying that we have some people trying
to hold to that old contract that it has
200 years old 150 years but
we definitely we cannot keep going with
that social contract we need a more
efficient social contract we need a
social contract that
can break with these
structures
and that can
help us to bring some
of the of the real solutions that i have
i have mentioned so
the problem is that
it was it
maybe is that it's not
it's not broken but it is it's a failed
one
it took us for 200 years without
delivering the proper solutions and it's
still there and still we have to deal
with that and that is the biggest
problem so we need a
we need a better a better social contact
with another program no i mean we
we don't socialize well
our socialization
also is
is
not an efficient one this is not the
right one you could see it in a
during computer times you could see it i
mean
and you could see it in practically
every country you you sometimes you have
very strict measures of
of guaranteeing all this
suddenly
but you could see that at the same time
they were
having people having clandestine parties
of 500 people
and we were people having transgender
parties of less than that but
they were
and that is uh the thing i mean we were
not we don't have this thing that
may exist here and i think it existed
but
i don't know so much of our places in
the city but in your way some have
existed this
this community life
that exists here that people are
responsible for the neighbor for what is
going on with the street with your
sidewalk uh with your tree with
everything is
how you have better community life and
that it means how you socialize better
you know
a wider view of solutions that may be
better but start a lot of things start
by you by you trying to to do things in
the in a in a better way but socializing
better if you just try to avoid the
rules avoid the norms
trying to create conditions that where
you can take some advantages but you
don't take the obligations and the
duties the responsibility that comes
with us will be very very difficult and
that is another problem that we have so
we have this problem of of the failed
social contract but we also have the
problem of of
that
the wrong way we socialize
secretary i think that we at this point
might open the floor for questions from
the audience if there is
one i have been so clear i don't think
they have questions
[Laughter]
yeah
hello um
so earlier today you talked about how
platforms like facebook can you please
because
yeah
they always say you talk about platforms
like facebook can be used to express
public opinion and use to kind of
promote like democratic ideals also we
see on platforms like facebook can
promote like hyperpolarization also like
to spread this information which can
lead to democratic blacks backsliding i
was wondering whether or not you thought
that um kind of regulating these social
media platforms should be initially
tackled by the international community
or something to be handled domestically
by each country
and
you know
first of all
if you
if you have common problems try to
resolve them together because if not you
will only will you you will only have a
cockroach effect i mean you will
stop it somewhere and it will just move
somewhere else
and
so i i think
i i was too attentive to whatever it
works and uh and and of course there are
some levels of of
of
the things that
they need to address to be addressed at
the national level because of course
every country has different scenarios
and they start from different points and
their social
their freedom of pressure on social
media or whatever is is a completely
it's completely different than the
country uh a couple of thousands of of
kilometers away
so there are specificities that will
be needed to be to address at the
national level
but
we need to to see the common problems
that this disgenerates and how we can
help each other in order to avoid
things that can
come with the digitalization of the of
politics
and uh
and
you see permanently these days
attack digital attacks coming
to your country from wherever else in
the world and and that is something of
course that we we need to have a better
understanding of how our
digital international relations should
be i mean
it cannot be a jungle it cannot be like
everybody
trying to prevail with the world tools
against others
but how we can be helpful in order to
create a better international community
and and of course
of course any rules that you bring into
the system
have to be you have to be design them
extremely carefully because
i mean i any drop that falls any
drop of ink that falls on
into
the freedom of expression it can be a
serious problem it will be a serious
problem
so
how you can manage that in order to
create even better conditions for
freedom of expression
and
i am i am one of the most insulted
people in media you know i'm
all my adversaries they have trolls and
forms of trolls all around i i only have
my humble account and i can
only say uh
the most evident truth because if one
day i lie
i will be killed
and
[Music]
so
as one of the most insulted
person in media i can tell you that
is good to keep freedom of expression
and and to assure that by all means and
i don't have any problem with anonymous
insulting me i don't have a problem with
that
but i i may have a problem with
anonymous committing crimes like
pedophilia or something like that so
those things and
anonymity cannot be protected in those
cases where you offend the law but
of course
and i consider that insulting a
politician is freedom of expression so
is is where you do that and and that and
that and can be assured
yes
good afternoon my name is the fox
international fellow here at yale first
of all thank you very much secretary
general for your time and very
interesting talk uh if you let me i have
two parts question uh the first is you
spoke a lot about democracy and its
importance and i wonder uh of course i
agree with it that this is very
important to build on which it's
possible to build good governments
uh to
develop rules
for uh in countries and in integration
processes but i wonder if we take into
account the example of china and we'll
look uh how it becomes the great power
how its economy is growing so
accordingly um the
people's conditions become better living
conditions become better
how we can
and taking into account what you said
before about democracy uh compare it
with what is happening in china uh and
the
second part of my question is
don't you think that
such kind of
building
integration processes
on such value as democracy reduces the
capability of organization to other
countries which
i would say don't have democratic
regimes
thanks a lot
yeah
and i
of course i will ask you to do so i i
always i have always said
democracy
is the best
in this hemisphere for development
security in this hemisphere
i can i can not go far beyond my
jurisdiction as you may realize
in any case every country has different
tools and different approaches i
i served as ambassador of ui to china
and
and of course i
i saw the process of a developing
country that and you could see that
every day
they were really
economically growing and
economically bringing
better conditions for the people and
socially bringing better conditions for
the people they day by day and
and practically every chinese person was
very optimistic that in the
uh next year he would be better than
this year and and that has been
quite uh
uh for uh
the
the reason for an optimist for for for
quite a while
uh
[Music]
they have a completely collective
uh pattern of working i mean is
for them
collective action and this
be a spirit of go doing the things
together the enhanced spirit of doing
the things together is a completely
different one that that we have in this
uh this hemisphere western hemisphere so
far
so
of course when we talk about about
systems uh
you can't uh
[Music]
i i don't know if i don't think you can
never go to an agreement of any kind
where you resign your liberties your
fundamental freedoms your
democratic rule of law you can't resign
that you have to keep it with you
because that will be a bigger loss than
anything that
that can happen
and
uh
of course uh i i always hope that in
that in that process uh more fundamental
freedoms will be available for for
chinese people and and that they may
develop and evolve in that direction and
that is an imperative that of course we
we always have to to have in mind but
what we
what i say is that we cannot lose what
we have about fundamental freedoms
because if we do that we are going to
really miss them i can tell you we are
going to really miss them and in this
continent
this continent
the closer the better our democracies
work
the better our conditions for access to
right for security and for development
that is a fact in this continent
in this continent
mr secretary general we
are out of time but i want to thank you
so much on behalf of clyde for taking
the time especially now considering the
circumstances to talk to us thank you so
much
[Laughter]
not
available